mein Thema heute Abend ist Robert Habeck
ignoriert deutsche Interessen wenige
Minister wurden ja in der deutschen
Medienlandschaft so überschätzt wie
Habeck die Grünen werden ja generell
sehr gerne medial gefeiert also die
Marketing Maschinerie braucht eigentlich
auch mal eine andere Partei die Welt
Chefredakteurin Dagmar Rosenfeld hatte
schon vor Jahren treffen auf den Punkt
gebracht damals hat sie gesagt alle 11
Minuten verliebt sich ein
stern-redakteur in einen grünen und so
war es auch eigentlich wieder bei Robert
Habeck als der Wirtschaftsminister wurde
feierte in die journali für seinen neuen
Kommunikationsstil auch die Wirtschaft
sei angetan hieß es gut die Begeisterung
der Wirtschaft die enthielt sich immer
meinem Kenntnisstand aber sei es darum
nun wird jedoch immer klarer Harbeck
ignoriert deutsche Interessen wie komme
ich denn darauf ich komme darauf weil in
seinem Kampf um den Klimawandel nimmt er
den Abstieg der deutschen Wirtschaft
nicht nur in Kauf nein er scheint ihn
sogar für geboten zu halten auch der
Wettbewerbsnachteil in unsere Industrie
aufgrund der Unterschiede bei den
Energie Kreisen zwischen den USA und
Europa erleidet der wird meines
Erachtens nach von ihm gekonnt ignoriert
meine erste Frage geht an Frau
Wagenknecht habe ich Recht habe ich
nicht recht und falls ja warum ignoriert
denn Robert Habeck die deutschen
Interessen so gekonnt ja also gibt es ja
nur zwei Erklärungen also entweder er
durchschaut nicht was er macht oder es
ist ihm egal und natürlich haben die
Grünen eigentlich schon immer so eine
Art Position nur teure Energie ist gute
Energie
ich finde das unglaublich
verantwortungslos und ich finde er
musste auch stärker unter Druck geraten
also es kann noch nicht sein dass diese
Regierung Sehnen Auges im Grunde das
Standbein unseres Wohlstandes kaputt
gehen lässt und das ist ja die Industrie
das ist aber auch das Handwerk das sind
kleine Unternehmen das ist der
Mittelstand und die alle leiden jetzt
unglaublich und andere
Wirtschaftsregionen profitieren davon
und ich finde das geht so nicht und das
darf man einfach nicht weiter hinnehmen
warum spricht Habeck das nicht an der
französische Minister hat es
beispielsweise angesprochen auf die
Unterschiede zwischen Amerika und
Deutschland und Blick auf die
Strompreise die er für uns ein
eklatanten Wettbewerbsnachteil
darstellen warum wird es nicht wirklich
auch mal kommuniziert unter welchen
Wettbewerbsnachteilen wir leiden ja also
es gibt sogar Zitat von Hardeck wo er so
gesagt hat ja also wir müssen jetzt
aufpassen dass wir nicht in ein
Handelskrieg mit Amerika kommen ja aber
der ist ja längst da der wird ja auch
längst geführt mit aller Brutalität und
gerade die Grünen sind da also wirklich
die unterwürfigsten und ein Punkt muss
man auch noch sehen es nützt ja noch
nicht mal dem Klima also gerade wenn wir
jetzt tatsächlich in Größenordnungen und
darauf läuft es ja hinaus amerikanisches
Fracking Gas kaufen in Zukunft das ist
ja nicht nur viel viel teurer als das
Gas was wir vorher hatten sondern das
ist auch extrem umweltschädlich oder
noch ein Beispiel wir haben doch jetzt
habe ich hat ja von der Reste Rampe
dieser Welt diese lng-terminals gekauft
das heißt dieses eine Terminal was jetzt
vor Schleswig-Holstein im Grunde in
Aktionen gehen soll da muss man wissen
das ist umwelttechnisch so schlecht dass
es vorher in Australien nicht eingesetzt
werden durfte weil es so viel Chlor ins
Wasser spült dass das dort tatsächlich
die die Meereslebewesen vernichten würde
und bei den Kohlekraftwerken ähnlich da
gehen jetzt kohlemeile ans Netz die
eigentlich alle Umweltstandards reißen
und gleichzeitig heucheln die Grünen sie
seien die Umweltpartei und ich habe
gerade gehört in München darf man nicht
mehr im Diesel jetzt in die Innenstadt
fahren also das ist so eine verlogene
Politik und ich finde also ich kann mich
da überhaupt nicht genug aufregen und es
ärgert mich einfach dass die immer so
weitermachen können dass sie Teil dieser
Regierung sind dass die anderen
Regierungsparteien das auch hinnehmen
und dulden also ich finde das kann nicht
so weitergehen weil alles was kaputt
gemacht wird das kommt nicht wieder das
muss man einfach auch wissen sie haben
die Grünen ja sogar als gefährlich
bezeichnet wenn ich das richtig in
Erinnerung habe also ich finde dass sie
gemessen an dem was sie an realen
Schaden anrichten aktuell die
gefährlichste Partei sind die wir im
Bundestag haben also da gab es einen
großen Aufschrei die AFD sei ja viel
gefährlicher ich finde die AFD also eine
wirklich zutiefst
unschöne und unerfreuliche Partei und
die hat Nazis in ihren Reihen die hat
Rechtsextremisten das finde ich alles
abscheulich aber die AFD kann überhaupt
nicht mehr als reden aber die Grünen
richten richtigen Schaden an sie sie
ruinieren den Wohlstand von Millionen
Menschen sie stürzen sie in die Armut
sie zerstören wenn man sie weitermachen
lässt Kernbereiche unserer Industrie die
dann einfach weg sind der
Industriestandort Deutschland ist in
Gefahr und das ist für mich hoch
gefährlich Herr Ribbeck ist der
Industriestandort Deutschlands in Gefahr
ja ist völlig unabhängig aus meiner
Sicht vom ukrainekrieg in Gefahr gewesen
weil die Grünen das stimmig Frau
Wagenknecht zu verstecken sich ganz
geschickt in der Ukraine Krise um ihre
Ideologie durchzusetzen
und es geht nur aus meiner Sicht noch
ein Stückchen weiter wenn Sie das Thema
Windkraft Solar nehmen kein Mensch redet
darüber welche pachten bezahlt werden
ich komme aus Mecklenburg-Vorpommern für
neue Windenergieanlagen von 56 Megawatt
werden bis zu 100.000 Euro Pacht pro
Anlage pro Jahr bezahlt ich da werden
einspeise vergütungsrenditen im
zweistelligen Prozentbereich erreicht
und Christian Lindner hat nicht umsonst
darauf hingewiesen dass bei dem Thema
zufallsgewinne die Windmüller ganz oben
mit dabei sind aber auch die Medien
spielen natürlich den ganzen
entscheidende Rolle alles was Grünes ist
gut
auch grüne Energie ist immer gut da wird
gar nicht in der fragt und das
Energiethema aus meiner Sicht hätte man
es relativ einfach lösen können indem
man die Atomkraftwerke hätte länger
laufen lassen Polen baut neue Schweden
tüchtigt hatten Endlager und so weiter
und was wir über die Jahre versäumt
haben ist uns auf eigene Füße auch im
Energiebereich zu stellen du kriegst in
Deutschland kein sandtagebombe
aufgeschlossen geschweige denn eigenes
Erdöl oder Erdgas gefördert und
lng-terminal hätten wir aus meiner Sicht
schon vor einem Jahrzehnt Wilhelmshaven
hatte Baurecht errichten müssen ähnlich
wie die Spanier zum Beispiel die haben
so etwas oder die Belgier oder die
Holländer und wir sind aus meiner Sicht
da im viel zu große Abhängigkeiten
geraten Frau mit der Serien im Blick von
außen die empfinden sie denn die
deutsche Wirtschaftspolitik erstmal
würde ich ganz deutlich sagen dass die
Krise in der wir uns befinden nicht an
den Grünen liegt sondern an Russlands
Angriffskrieg gegen die Ukraine und an
den hohen Abhängigkeiten die wir von
Russland hatten und immer ja auch noch
haben in Teilen und dass wir das eben
völlig unterschätzt haben also unsere
hohe Abhängigkeit
verantwortlich machen wollen eher die
Union dann wahrscheinlich fahren ja ich
würde es ich würde gar nicht die Union
alleine verantwortlich machen sondern
das war ein ich würde mal insgesamt
gesellschaftliches und politisches und
auch wirtschaftliches versagen wir haben
halt über Jahrzehnte hinweg geglaubt das
gegenseitige ab dass wir
entgegenseitigen Abhängigkeiten uns
bewegen also wir sind abhängig von
russischem Gas und Öl und Russland ist
eben abhängig von unserem Geld von
unseren Devisen von unserem Euro und
weil sie eben abhängig sind würden sie
uns den Gashahn nicht abdrehen und wir
hatten aber auch die Erfahrung
Vergangenheit waren noch nie ein
Wettbewerbsvorteil also man kann nicht
sagen dass vor dem Krieg Deutschland so
niedrige Strompreise hatte das ist mein
Wettbewerbsvorteil war das stimmt nicht
nur habe ich auch gar nicht gesagt aber
unsere Wettbewerbsfähigkeit speist dich
vor allen Dingen auch aus der hohen
Qualität der Produkte die wir eben auch
herstellen aber auch der internationalen
Verflechtung aber um nochmal
zurückzukommen wir haben eben diese
Abhängigkeiten falsch eingeschätzt und
wir haben auch die Rationalität
Russlands falsch eingeschätzt und wir
hätten eben früher darauf reagieren
müssen und früher unsere Energie
Bezugsquellen diversifizieren müssen wir
hatten also viel früher auch am
lng-terminals bauen müssen und auch
wahrscheinlich noch mehr und schneller
auch in Erneuerbare Energien investieren
müssen und wir hatten ja die Debatte
schon mal während der Verhandlung mit
den USA zu Titels zum international also
zum transatlantischen Handels- und
Investitionsabkommen und da wollten wir
alle das LNG nicht so von den USA und
jetzt jetzt hat es uns eben erwischt und
in dieser Krise umzusteuern das ist
natürlich wahnsinnig schwierig und das
das vor der großen Herausforderung steht
eben gerade die Ampelkoalition ich finde
man muss sich aber in der Debatte
ehrlich machen wenn sie sagen in
Erneuerbare Energien investieren erneuer
Technologien müssen grundlastfähig
gemacht werden klar rufen wir das Thema
Wasserstoff auf da habe ich heute ein
nachteilsfaktor zwischen 4 und 8 und
über die Speicherfähigkeit und
Wasserstoff werden wir im nächsten
Jahrzehnt jedenfalls industriell und
wirtschaftsmäßig nicht werden reden
können das heißt wir werden wenn das so
weitergeht jetzt völlig unabhängig noch
mal von dem Thema Ukraine weil der Weg
den haben die Grünen dahin wollen die
beschreiten und und der wird beschritten
werden das heißt unsere Strompreise sind
auch deswegen so hoch weil wir natürlich
ganz stark auf erneuerbare Energien
gesetzt haben und ganz nebenbei kommen
noch mal zu dem Thema pachten und so
weiter zurück diese ganze erneuerbaren
Energien Geschichte ist die größte
vermögensumverteilung der letzten Jahre
und Jahrzehnte in Deutschland von den
nicht Besitzenden zu den Besitzenden
weil die nicht Besitzenden wir alle
bezahlen die erneuerbaren Energien und
wenn sie sich mal die Strukturen
angucken gut es gibt ein paar Windparks
aus Wissenschaften in Schleswig-Holstein
war bei mir zu Hause wird das
überwiegend in Mecklenburg-Vorpommern
über Fonds geregelt wenn man sich
angucken die Investitionen im
Offshore-Bereich dann sind dann die ganz
großen dabei also ich finde diese
Debatte muss ehrlicher gemacht werden
und die hat es nicht nur mit grüner
Ethnologie zu betrachten sondern sie ist
auch industriepolitisch
sicherheitspolitisch zu betrachten an
der Stelle und auch die Zeiträume sorry
finde ich muss man sich auch mal ehrlich
machen das wird nicht alles morgen und
übermorgen realisiert werden können da
werden wir Jahre und Jahrzehnte brauchen
ich glaube sicher ist der Hund das kann
bei der überhaupt nicht bestreiten dass
wir einerseits natürlich langfristig
eine Veränderung brauchen weg von den
fossilen Energieträgern aber
andererseits zur Zeit technologisch
überhaupt nicht in der Lage sind die
Erfordernisse auch die
energieerfordernisse unserer Industrie
mit erneuerbaren Energien abzudecken
also da stimme ich Ihnen ja völlig zu
aber insoweit war das eigentlich und und
insoweit sind wir abhängig also wir sind
abhängig von denen die uns
Energieträger liefern wir werden auch
zukünftig abhängig sein ja nur weil sie
hat also eigentlich wollte ich auf sie
reagieren und widersprechen gar nicht
auf sie hören Rewe weil ich finde immer
zusammen wir waren wir haben uns
abhängig gemacht wir sind ein
rohstoffarmes Land und wir sind ein Land
das wenig Energieträger hat wir können
mit erneuerbaren Energien ein Teil der
Energieversorgung abdecken aber wir
haben im Bereich der fossilen Energien
Abhängigkeiten wir hätten die
Abhängigkeiten natürlich auch im
Nuklearbereich also war immer gesagt
wird Frankreich steht besser da weil sie
eine weil sie ganz viel Atomstrom haben
ja warum haben sie den Atomstrom
frankreich hat eine intelligentere
Regierung als Deutschland die haben
nämlich darauf bestanden dass alles was
Sie für zum Betreiben ihre Atommeiler
brauchen dass das aus den
sanktionspaketen ausgeklammert wird weil
das Uran kommt zu großen Teilen aus
Russland das angereicherte Rohren und
das wird dann auch wieder nach Russland
zurückgeschickt also die französische
Atomstrom hängt ganz eng an der
Kooperation mit Russland also das sollte
man nicht ganz vergessen wenn man sagt
wir hätten einen anderen Weg einschlagen
können oder einschlagen sollen wir haben
gesagt wir setzen auf Gas das russische
Gas ist konkurrenzlos billig gewesen
sehr viel billiger als das amerikanische
LNG Gas wir haben die Hälfte aus
Russland geholt das war ja eigentlich
schon eine der Diversifizierung und dass
der Gasherd abgedreht wurde ich meine
russland hat seit den 70er Jahren
Deutschland vorher noch Westdeutschland
also selbst im Kalten Krieg zuverlässig
beliefert das hatte ja was mit den
Sanktionen zu tun und deswegen finde ich
ich finde den ukrainekrieg natürlich
auch ein riesiges Verbrechen ich wünsche
mir dass man viel mehr tut um ihn zu
beenden aber die explodierenden
Energiekosten sind nicht die direkte
Folge des ukrainekriegs sie sind die
Folge dieser sanktionspakete die dann
einen Wirtschaftskrieg begonnen haben
auf den Russland reagiert hat und das
hätte man sich vorher überlegen können
Aktionen man kann noch das Verhalten
Russlands nicht so stehen lassen und
darauf aber wenn dieser Reaktion in
Russland gar nicht schaden sprechen
noch über die Sanktionen ganz
ausführlich ich würde gerne einmal
ich will alle ihre Argumente heute noch
hören aber einmal möchte ich gerne Sie
noch Fragen zu dem Thema Robert Habeck
und der Wirtschaftspolitik als
Praktikerin sie haben eine Bäckerei auch
mit mehreren Filialen wie zufrieden sind
Sie denn mit unserem Wirtschaftsminister
also ich muss sagen absolut gar nicht
zufrieden seit mehreren Wochen kämpfe
ich ganz aktiv mit vielen meiner
Kollegen gegen genau diese hohen Preise
wie wir jetzt entlastet werden sollen
wir haben es geschafft dass wir in der
Politik gehört werden ich selbst konnte
mit Herrn Habig sprechen
und kann einfach nicht nachvollziehen
dass uns nicht geholfen wird und uns das
meine ich wirklich die Lebensmittel
produzierenden Betriebe wir sind
systemrelevant das sind nicht nur die
Bäcker das sind auch die Metzger das
sind die Molkereien wir sollen entlastet
werden beziehungsweise gebremst und
gedeckelt um es mal an diesen Worten zu
sagen der Politik genauso wie
Privathaushalte das ist nicht möglich
ich war sehr erschrocken dass Herrn
Habeck nicht klar war als ich mit ihm
gesprochen habe dass wir ganz andere
Preise bisher hatten als die
Privathaushalte er sagte dann dann sind
sie ja Industrie nein das bin ich nicht
ich bin ein kleines mittelständiges
Unternehmen mit 60 Mitarbeitern aber
natürlich wenn wir mehrere stand also
was heißt Standorte wir haben mehrere
Verkaufsstellen dann habe ich wesentlich
mehr Energie die ich benötige und auch
zum Backen des Brotes brauche ich
wesentlich mehr Energie als zum Heizen
einer vierköpfigen Familie
beispielsweise
ganz klar kann ich bei uns sagen sind
das ungefähr 450.000 Kilowattstunde per
anno und wir kommen ungefähr das gesamte
Bäckereihandwerk von und das ist auch so
was die Politik nicht weiß oder viele
Politiker nicht wissen wie sich
überhaupt der Strom und der Gaspreis
zusammensetzt also ich habe eben immer
gehört wir hatten ja so niedrige Preise
ja der Grundpreis war sehr sehr niedrig
die Umlagen waren schon immer sehr hoch
wir sind zum Beispiel auch nie
ausgenommen wurden von der EEG-Umlage
aber um es mal in der faktisch zu sagen
wir kommen von einem Gaspreis der bei im
Schnitt zwei Cent der reine Arbeitspreis
dann kam morgen von 2,4 sind oben drauf
so dass der Bäcker im Schnitt 5 Cent
maximal gezahlt hat und wir sollen jetzt
gedeckelt werden bei 12 Cent wegen also
die Mehrwertsteuer noch abgezogen das
heißt wir sind dabei einer Verdopplung
und beim Strom ist es exorbitant also
beim Strom kommen wir von dem
Arbeitskreis von vier Cent und sind dann
brutto mit allen Umlagen im Moment bei
15 sind das sieht man mal wie das ist
also der große Teil sind wirklich
Steuern Steuern steuern ohne die
Mehrwertsteuer und wir sollen jetzt auf
40 Cent minus Mehrwertsteuer das heißt
37 Cent da ist es mehr als eine
Verdopplung wenn das so in die Tat
umgesetzt wird dann funktioniert das
nicht